à quelques semaines de la désignation du
goncourt des lycéens 2012 ces élèves de
première littéraire du lycée jean vilar
de plaisir se réunissaient pour discuter
et partager leurs impressions sur les
oeuvres sélectionnées entre peste et
choléra l'enfant grec ou encore lame de
fond ces lycéens ont découvert un autre
univers de lecture qui parfois était un
peu éloignés de leur livre préféré
c'est pas forcément steen deniaud c'est
un certain qu'ils m'ont pas trop plu
mais d'autres qui sont intéressants
parce qu'ils sont différents des nids de
classiques c'est une bonne aventure
quelque chose d'extraordinaire enfin
entendue comment ça m'aurait pas à tirer
en dehors puisque c'est pas mon style
des classiques
ces lycéens avaient 11 livres à lire en
deux mois si parfois se plonger dans les
chapitres a été difficile les élèves se
sont prêtés au jeu et le regard
littéraire a changé les élèves sont
lancés dans la lecture là depuis la 4
septembre donc certains ont déjà tout lu
sur des onze livres donc c'est vraiment
très très bien d'autres 600 mais un peu
plus tard mais là ça y est il commence à
y avoir une bonne dynamique de lecture
et surtout leurs lectures ont mûri donc
ils ont un regard beaucoup plus aiguisée
une critique beaucoup plus fine et ça
c'est vraiment intéressant il leur reste
quelques jours pour parcourir les
dernières pages des livres pas encore
ouvert un délégué de classe se rendre à
la dernière étape au mois de novembre à
paris pour participer à la nomination du
lot rien 2012